Wall Street is Las Vegas for smart
people.
It's where you take your money if you
want to have the odds on your side and
like Las Vegas,
it's full of people who think they have
the winning system to get even further
ahead.
Hedge funds,
value investors,
your uncle who assured that they connect
is the next big thing and especially Jim
Kramer,
they're all trying to outsmart everyone
else and this makes sense.
The legend and mystique around Wall
Street is that if you're clever enough
you can be like mitis ensuring
everything you touch will become gold
and there's a clip from the movie
limitless that perfectly encapsulates
this allure of Wall Street.
Super Intelligent guy gets on Wall
Street and from nothing makes millions
because he just sees things.
The others don't.
He outsmarts them.
My new friend Kevin Dileo showed me how
you could leverage two and a half times
your cash at the day training.
Why are you buying that?
The CEO was just indicted but not for
the big fat defense contract.
He bribed his way into that.
Still on.
It should be announced next week.
At the end of the week,
my brokerage account contained over $2
million.
Now,
of course you have to take out the
exaggerated Hollywood elements,
but for many people,
this is the sexy side of Wall Street.
Bring me your poor masses and if you're
smart will make you rich.
And many people believe that story and
chase,
it's promise.
But there was an idea that challenge
that narrative that radically suggested
that it may be impossible to improve
your odds beyond the average.
Even brilliant money managers,
hedge funds,
and the best investors may be no better
than monkeys at picking stocks.
Number one rule of Wall Street.
Nobody,
okay if you're Warren Buffet,
if you cheer me,
but nobody knows if a stock is going to
go up,
down,
sideways,
or in fucking circles,
at least of all stock brokers.
But before we get to monkeys,
let's first talk about the big question,
the question.
Some of the greatest minds in the world
have spent their lives trying to answer
the one that would make you rich.
What will the price of a stock b
tomorrow?
And the answers to this question are as
numerous as you might expect for an
alchemy recipe.
There is fundamental analysis,
technical analysis,
buying hold,
value,
invest in growth investing.
I could go on pretty much forever.
And the point is at this time it was
thought that if you had money,
you needed to find a genius on Wall
Street to invest that money for you.
Someone who through some secret
strategy,
manage your wealth in exchange for a
fee.
The idea was that their expertise would
get you returns in your money that would
more than pay for their secret formula,
and this is how you made the big bucks
if you're on Wall Street managing
people's money and charging a fee for
it.
Okay?
And amidst these competing views of the
stock market and wealthy wealth
managers,
along comes an American economist,
Burton Malkiel,
who looks at the market and essentially
throws a monkey wrench at the
traditional theories in his book,
a random walk down Wall Street.
He says,
no,
you're all wrong.
The stock market can't be consistently
predicted by any theory.
The only predictable thing we have about
the market is it.
The whole thing tends to increase over
time.
No one is able to consistently pick
winners over anyone else and boldest of
all,
he predicted a blindfolded monkey
throwing darts at newspaper's financial
pages could select a portfolio that
would do just as well as one carefully
selected by experts.
If this is true Malka,
it goes on to say,
instead of paying big bucks to Wall
Street to let experts manage your
wealth,
the best thing to do is to find a
minimum fee fund that buys up hundreds
of stocks without discrimination for
winners and losers and just holds them
passively because the future of a stock
is fundamentally unknowable anyways,
because if your average return is the
same for both strategies,
expert management and monkey management,
why would anyone pay for the experts
into the index fund of the early
seventies exactly the kind of low fi
fund that now kale proposes.
You buy it,
pay a tiny maintenance fee,
and it just buys and holds hundreds of
stocks.
Now,
if you're one of those expert investors
and index funds seems both silly and
insulting.
Random stocks,
no technical analysis,
no psychological analysis,
no chart analysis.
This was a challenge to the very ethos
of Wall Street,
a challenge to the idea of the midas
investor and over the next decades,
the battle between expert funds and
monkey funds raged on and after almost
50 years of data,
the results are in and it's
overwhelming.
You can find hundreds of studies on this
because this is one of the most
surprising and over analyze things and
finance.
But here are the headlines.
Over the last 15 years,
index funds outperformed 90% of actively
managed funds when you account for their
fees.
Let me repeat that.
90% not 50% 90% of the smartest people
on Wall Street made less money than
monkeys and the 10% well,
given the averages,
it starts looking a lot like luck rather
than skill.
After all given enough investors,
it's self evident that someone will gain
above average returns just by sheer
luck.
And we also have a study that even the
funds that do beat the index fund one
three,
five years struggled to continue that
positive performance and the number that
do continue that positive performance
year over year is about the number that
we'd expect from blind chance.
Just because you won 15 coin flips in a
row doesn't mean you're any more likely
to win the next one.
Let's talk about why the future of the
stock market can't be predicted.
This is a long theorized idea called the
efficient market hypothesis and even for
the people who don't subscribe to that
idea,
there's another confounding problem at
work here.
It's a game theory problem.
It's a situation where there are so many
rational actors in the system that the
market cannot be reasonably predicted
because each time someone gets a winning
method of valuing stocks,
the next person will find a way to
incorporate that strategy into a new
strategy to be the first strategy.
In other words,
everyone's strategy must take into
account other investing strategies into
their formula for how the market will
swing,
but it's self referential because the
other rational actors will feasibly be
trying to incorporate your strategy into
their investing strategy.
And this is kind of where it all breaks
down.
It's an ever evolving game that you'll
never win it long enough to beat the
market average.
So while occasionally there are exploits
in the market,
they rarely lasts for long and they
almost always found by different people.
Even Warren Buffett who is on the very
short list of people you might argue has
consistently beating the stock market
when asked what to invest in,
doesn't bother naming his own company or
any other.
Instead he has a simple answer that
would make Malka smile.
He recommends you go get some index
funds.
It turns out that predicting winners and
losers is impractical over long periods
of time.
There's no such thing as a consistently
winning strategy over the long haul.
It's much more like gambling where the
house odds are on your side,
you're going to win some and you're
going to lose them.
And you can't predict which,
but if you stay around long enough,
you'll win more than you lose.
Really the only thing you shouldn't do
is pay someone to come up with fancy
models and strategies for something that
ultimately comes to chance.
Just go and get some money.
Peace.
Hey,
thanks for watching the video.
This is a huge topic.
So there are things that I didn't get
to.
Uh,
automatic tax loss harvesting robot
investors,
which have brought down the cost of
active management significantly.
Smart Beta etfs,
which Malka El himself is a fan of tons
of stuff that was a little bit outside
the scope of this video for time's sake,
but I left links below.
So if you're interested in sinking your
teeth a little more into this topic,
you can do soca.
So go check that out.
Also we're going to be having a
discussion on the reddits,
so if you want to talk about this a
little more in detail and interact with
me,
uh,
go there,
artists to the music as always are
linked and I will see you guys next time
we got,
we've got a fun one coming up next time,
so keep your eye out for that.
Should be about a week or two out in
other news.
Got a little bit of an announcement to
make.
Pretty excited about that.
Uh,
I'll link some pictures or something.
I hope you have as wonderful of a month
as I'm having and I will see you guys
next time.